before we begin that I just wanted to
say a little bit about our plans for a
discussion period today since it's such
a lovely afternoon the organizers are
proposing that we all go over to the
free house which is for just couple
blocks over that way they have a nice
courtyard in the back which is open here
we can get healed beer or soft drink
whatever you like and I hope everybody
can come we'll have a nice discussion
relax there we get there around
four-thirty issue so it should be so
proud i think we can get a bunch of big
tables together so that's the plan for
discussion this afternoon and our
speaker now is sit away who is at
Stanford and he's going to talk to us a
little bit about interactive language
would take it away it's okay thank you
for having me I'm Syrah and my talk will
be interactive language learning from
the extremes this is joint work with my
advisors Percy and Chris as well as to
undergrad who worked with me over the
summer so the goal of this research is
to address and to natural natural
language interfaces and in particular
the language understanding part
currently as speech recognition is
working better the understanding part is
becoming the limiting factor and is
often made fun of so in Kobe's show
after a few come up few runs Colbert
said for the love of God the cameras are
on give me something and Siri reply what
kind of place are you looking for camera
stores or churches so while it's a
forgivable that's through the process of
learning language that mistakes are made
currently when these mistakes are made
there is no way it will correct them and
learn from the mistakes so that they are
not made for the next user and this is
our approach which is to to have systems
that receives I received feedback
your slave from users and improve
through use so there are a few reasons
why this is necessary often you need to
adapt to users my regular week weekday
alarm is different from yours and maybe
people use water language interface for
special domains where the language used
deviates significantly and also we want
to perform really complex actions such
as call Bob every hour on to you he
picks up stop after it tries which is
but beyond the capability of current
natural language interfaces we pose two
questions was how can we learn from
scratch really quickly and the other is
how can we learn and build up too
complex and custom actions and the first
part deals with the learning from
scratch when you spur ition for this is
the concept of language game from wigan
Stein who famously said that language
derives its meaning from use and we
instantiate a form of the language game
it's a goal-oriented activity where a
language is a consequence of trying of
the the party is trying to reach the
goal so in particular is a cooperative
game between a human and a computer
player so the human player has a goal in
mind but cannot perform any actions
directly I must you use language to
communicate with the computer player on
the computer player on the other hand
does not know the goal but can perform
the actions some particular set of
actions and furthermore the computer
does not understand any language in the
beginning so to succeed in this game the
part of the human player must teach the
computer player a suitable language and
adapt to the capability of the
sooner and the computer does the best
they can to learn the language quickly
through this interactive process so know
the human also does not know what yeah
what actions in the computer can perform
but roughly there's a domain so maybe
the human can guess what kind of actions
are wanted okay so in particular we to
does yeah a blocks world this gonna be
one shot or is this a sequence of many
different related tasks that figure so
it's a it's a sequence of relate so yeah
it's I yeah iterated process yeah ok so
our particular setting as in a blocks
world where you have a starting set of
blocks and ago as a set of blocks that
the humans trying to reach so in order
to do that the human would produce an
utterance such as removed red and the
computer performs in you know you know
you know beginning just some random
actions but it returns the possible
actions yeah you know list so I I wrote
down some of the possible actions but
the human never sees these actions it
just sees the resulting set of blocks
right and from from this list the human
selects the wine he wants and the
computer learns from that selection so
this is the human see reaction being
performed or just the end result just so
so the human sees the end result of the
action but not and not the actual
program yeah of each of the four
candidates Yeah Yeah right I'll show
show you something more country yeah so
in this case the human can just say
whatever they want and
and the wheel does this one would do its
best to figure out what's happening so
it could be Chinese or some or pick at
it okay so i'll show you how how this
works yeah so in the beginning we just
need to perform some pretty simple
actions such as remove bra and then yep
from c-list you pick and that's remove
bra and oh yeah and now now you're your
computer should know was her removal
brothers but that's not what we want
orange yeah so you pick from the list I
was just scrolling down the list until
you find the co-state accepted and right
so you as the starts with a really
simple actions like just removing a
color and the proceeds to maybe talking
about the leftmost rightmost of a set
add colors to another color
well I guess we were taught us remove
orange so so I add orange is pretty
natural but otherwise yeah actually it
should perform some basic generalization
right so once it learns the color then
actions that takes colors as arguments
can be learned more easily and this
precedes he kind of increase in
difficulty and concretely that's just
based on a length of the logical form
required until until the the human the
computer can together perform more
fairly complicated sequence of actions
see like in the very first step there is
no connection between was typing in the
candidates that robot offers in a wire
yes you know very first up it's just a
randomness so then would maybe you'll
get to this but it seems surprising that
the robot will generate in the first
thousand things the thing right nicely
yeah oh my gods have little bit into
that yeah but I agree okay so that's the
game and we'll talk a little bit about
how the computer works and the
formulation is semantic parsing which is
converting language into logical forms
or in our case really into programs so
in our logical forms has a few
predicates like add color right Mose
leftmost remove some set operations so
notice that multiple actions can
correspond to the same a block
configuration for any given particular
for any given starting state and we use
parsing fairly loosely where we
basically generates logical forms from
the smallest size through the largest to
to larger size score all these
candidates with a model
and us being searched to prove the set
of logical forms that we are considering
and to in order to score these logical
forms we use the log linear model with
features defined over the utterance and
the logical form we really and really
features are arbitrary strings in our
case right so for any given input X and
Z you you can define a function that
map's them to a 223 and the learning
process just assigns a weight to the
presence of that string except we don't
really have access to the formula Z and
instead we learn from you know the
denotation what we call the denotation
which is the result of executing z on
the starting state why and to do that we
maximize the probability of all formulas
that is consistent with the observed
denotation
so just upgrade our update this lost
functional of integrand that's that's
how learning works so the only
parameters that are being learned
curable cadence right yeah and the
features are the sort of individual
features in the right so they are so the
choice of features determines how well
you can generalize right so for example
i give here you can just memorize x and
z right that's the second example
feature which owns generalize very well
at all right but if you break down all
the features compositionally then you
can expect better generalization yeah
what's it sizes 10-5 that's English text
yeah so so you could say one feature
right I'm just really driving the point
that just by using this formulation
doesn't mean all that much unless you
specify which features you are using so
this particular case we could have a
feature that's just the size of the
utterance versus the size of the logical
form and you maybe you can capture
things like if their sizes are two
different then perhaps it's not quite a
good napping and that would reflect BB
reflecting a negative weight okay right
but the particular features we use right
we wanted to generalize a lot better so
we break a pricked on both the entrance
and the logical form into parts so on
the other side we have uni grams by
grams and skip grams of the of the
address and only on the logical form
side really it's similar except sorry
not illogical for me is it a tree right
right right so yeah so this other logic
the logical form an example is just yeah
that formula is I example yeah yeah so
and you can yeah it has a tree structure
yeah so it's really very similar on the
logical form side but because we have a
tree structure we can do a little bit
more than then diagrams where we can
capture the local structure at the yi at
each node of the tree and the real
features are just cross products between
the two right so through learning maybe
you are learning like whenever the token
put appears you should add something
right and put orange perhaps add orange
to something so what is this list of
possible features so that star star how
do you know that was a reasonable what
is this list of features so hold it up
yeah right so based on the logical form
present you will generate add star star
because ad is just use the entire Lord
this logical form made use of the
predicate add yeah yeah um yes and the
predicates are known for yeah the
predicates are known to me and to the
system but it's not known to the to the
human player yeah right and through
learning you want to operate features
like put corresponds to add and perhaps
down way its features like puts
corresponding so right so really a
feature is just a string right it's in
this case that that string and yeah and
if you see more addresses that contains
unknown new new words and then then you
will you will have more features and
more parameters in your model
yeah and learning is just assigning
weights to these features are very free
and that's our computer model and we
actually tried to get a bunch of people
to play this game we got 100 Turkish to
play this and they produce just over
10,000 utterances they were given fairly
minimal instruction and in particular no
examples to avoid biasing their language
use really all the instruction that they
were given is the paragraph here yeah
and some player actually enjoyed the
game we will measure will measure
performance based on how much scrolling
they had to do right so so if they were
very successful at teaching the computer
then maybe most of the sentences general
generalized correctly and they don't
need to do very much scrolling if
nothing generalizes or you things
contradict with each other and then they
have to scroll a lot to get to the
choice they want yes ladies could go
kind of poorly is if if the teacher kind
of keeps on giving extremely simple
tasks computer right then obviously the
computer will learn to do very well with
minimal amount of scrolling on the part
of the teacher but ID and you haven't
really learned
interesting so how do you make sure that
there are enough non-trivial yeah so in
some sense there's a stop limit right so
you you're you're given there's many
steps and you have to your complex that
he has to yeah you have to be able to
accomplish yeah did you select how
complex each task Lazar ya Salam part
isn't sub like where is scientific
that's just say yeah kind of a level
like process yeah yeah and it's roughly
based on the length of the logical form
yeah but what's so great so you
essentially you know beginning you kind
of teacher colors and then teach it like
things that require fuel colors now
require set confidence and on to you can
do everything yeah so you know brackets
is the amount of scrolling that players
had to do and we are looking currently
looking at the most successful players
who didn't need to screw very much so
they tend to be very precise and
consistent using the same term for the
same action but you can you can use
English or you can use some short form
which I you by using a short form it's
perhaps easier to be consistent then
going down the performance metric
average players tend to be slightly
inconsistent using say reinsert put ad
for the same term or in some case
because they don't know anything about
the computer actions day is just
mismatch the action space right so I
guess I didn't really precise define
precisely define the action space but
base basically it's represented using
left right and that's the set operations
on them so we don't really represent
number
you could if you represent numbers with
like Church encoding but that's very
long and really in practice we don't
represent numbers so if you use numbers
we can't really do exactly what you want
but the system could still learn things
like the number one corresponds to left
and the high number corresponds to right
and that kind of things but it harms
your performance then there are yeah
there's also the worst performing
players tend to be a bit spammy vague or
in some case just didn't bother to
tokenize for the system these I thought
I made minimal assumptions of our
language which is just we have units
that are tokenized but sometimes they
just give me a whole unit and in our
case no system doesn't really generalize
and that kind of keeps you up baseline
on how much learning is doing for you so
besides the English traders we have one
player who use polish and another player
who used polish notation we observe
players adapt to the task by becoming
more consistent and more precise
so looking quantitatively at how well
learning works our full model basically
gets this is accuracy so the percentage
of times where the first candidates
returned is correct throughout the game
so the best model that we use gets
thirty-three percent accuracy overall
which is much higher for the top 10
players and because you you do right
once you thought like remove red you can
use remove read and memorize does Ron
seventeen percent okay i think i was
actually skip pragmatics which is just a
way to make learning a little bit
quicker so we can tell me talk about
something newer and more exciting right
so since we took this game the game was
just a lie and there were more people
playing that which gives us more data
and and this is like very very diverse
dinner if using all kinds of languages
english various foreign languages and
doug computer like languages but you
have no it's not that they have similar
problems like occasional mismatch with
action space and present organization
issues alright so at least for this
setting we were able to learn from
scratch fairly quickly and we observe
that people adapt to the computer
there are some fairly obvious drawbacks
to the approach one is selection can't
possibly scale well for the number of
logical forms that grows exponentially
it's lit and for the particular setting
we were considering each user has a
private language so even if there are
many many users using the system it
wouldn't continue to improve and finally
while it might be a feature that you
have a bit because arguably if if you
have you know if if the others can learn
from the better users we know the and
the number of people with witnesses so
if the the worst users can learn from
the better users than the number of
people yeah I thought I think that you
have modified the setting a little bit
to make it the case but I'm just saying
for our procedure for this particular
work we wanted just a very clean setting
where each person is pi by themselves
right I mean oh my point is that that
keeping them in isolation is a
constraint that you don't need to keep
flow yeah yeah of course so a relaxed
that yeah but the unions are the
drawbacks
which which is really the motivation for
for our follow-up work yes have you
considered letting the players actually
design their own teaching tasks I don't
design their own yeah you're very very
interesting so I think we all get we are
we also moved a little in that direction
too so maybe you can see if yeah but I
agree with you there shouldn't be like
restricted to some task that I imagine
okay so that's that's the motivation for
our full of work which will call
naturalizing up for running language
which is in some sense the opposite of
learning from scratch where we all start
from with a programming language yeah
and ago is we want to handle really
complex actions and I don't see how you
can do that by a search and yeah and we
wanted to do it in a community setting
where people people share whatever they
thought and the system continues to
improve and lastly because ultimately
you are trying to get a computer to
perform that task for house it's good to
accommodate it a little bit to the
action space ok so the protein was very
similar to what common stock move this
meeting
I see okay so yeah then this is our our
solution not naturalization so we see
the system with a core programming
language it defines the action space but
perhaps tedious to use and then user
would teach the system by defining new
things like providing feedback like X
means why and you know process we want
to evolve the language to be more
natural and that's very basic I learn a
programming language phone data so right
so to be a bit more concrete but yeah
the core language is on big us and
composes tractable II and the definition
is something like a three for three by
four Red Square is three red columns of
height for and if you have this kind of
supervision the user is telling the
system exactly how to generalize and you
don't have to observe many examples and
you further how to generalize so yes
some sense this is the Montague approach
to the meaning of language wherever take
his famous quote i think when
implication you can Troy's his he would
say language derives its meaning from
definition
yeah and we want to do this in a
community setting and and the particular
world we are we are doing doing the Z is
a box a world where each walk soldiers
has attributes coordinates color and we
think of the world as the database with
the relations and just a few
domain-specific relations like the
directions essentially and we use to
domain specific actions add and move and
the core language is basically the
design to be more interpreter play a
design to interpolate well with natural
language but it has your usual
programming language features like
control flows we really want to avoid
explicit variables so we use this
formalism called lambda TCS which is
which basically makes tree structure
join very convenient and very low free
so you can say has color yellow means
everything everything that has color
yellow and you can do set operations you
can do right has color color of has
ruined so that means cow color of the
things in ruin and to further avoid
having explicit variables we have an
implicit a selection for you 24 for the
users to refer to this is like the the
turtle yeah logo to help people build up
a hierarchically we have a few scoping
parentals alright so that's the language
most of it is just very very generic and
fits into the database viewpoint of the
world except for a few domains
for actions and relations can you say
what this means it's just the current
thing is selected okay yeah so okay so
I'm supposed to show you now how
definition works how learning how the
learning process works here okay so
that's the the interface and I think
it's fresh so I wanted to add palm tree
and this is just eat from the very
beginning right it doesn't know anything
about language only knows look for
language sorry yes so so i might say add
trunk three and still it doesn't
understand so this would be
okay and i can i can define a trunk so
perhaps then after after I did the trunk
I go to the very top I select some some
spaces will be besides the top and add a
leaf right so so far out some I think as
a reason maybe that's a reasonable palm
tree okay so we should have a palm tree
now
and we okay so we use the probabilistic
model to handle scoping choices and what
once you have a palm tree you can use a
palm tree ye in further definitions so
perhaps I want like a row of palm trees
and I can do
okay anyways so a little bit tedious so
this is a row of palm tree of five
spaces apart perhaps okay yeah and on
you're using you can you can you can do
this this kind of things repeatedly so
it's yeah as you can see right initially
it's fairly fairly tedious I have to do
that bracketing and basically writing a
programming language but but so quickly
it's getting powerful ray I can you use
this pretty simple command to bake this
complex relatively complex action
so basically you can define anything in
terms of things that's that are already
defined all the way tracking all the way
back to the core language and the model
is similar to before except now it's
over their relations instead of just
logical forms and the and because of the
the change to learning from definitions
we can now handle much more complex
denotations we still use learning from
denotation now and now there isn't a big
chance for random logical forms to
collide in the denotation so it's mostly
to handle its coping choices which is
only intuitive to most people I did the
previous thing if you did something like
add fallen tree Jenny spaces apart with
it that's okay so let's see
okay so yeah so the contra channel is a
little bit yeah right so a derivation is
just an object that describes the
process going from the go into the
formula from the address including the
information like which rules are used
where each component come from
categories types and the like yeah so we
still we still have various features and
now now the most important wise probably
just which rules which will you use and
that essentially turns your CFG to a
pcfg but in addition to that we have the
indicators whether the rule is induced
or core and because this is now a
community setting we want to capture a
little bit about say which user likes
things from which other user so we have
like friends features and perhaps some
users just generally do better better
thanks so maybe just because the the
author is the dis user that rule is
better so that's the author feature and
Jen maybe people like rules that they
author themselves a little bit better so
that's the self feature yeah and just
and the rest of it is pretty standard
for semantic parsing just capture a
little bit of context on top of the
context-free grammar yeah
so the primary way we learn here why is
that the good it's a heuristic which is
a little context around the context p
yeah so so clear look some some things
are definitely not context-free right so
I a tread left times three maybe that's
a that's your alternative but loops and
hacks right instead of repeat three and
right left but but if the user has that
like add red to row five times three
then you can't just say like action
times three is loop right am I might be
times might become a multiplication so
if you want to really model you yeah
it's yeah it's not completely contacts
yeah
yes I learning is based through through
definitions and I showed you what
definitions look like we want to induce
a bunch of high-precision rules from
these definitions and the way to do it
is essentially a substitute matching
part right and under okay I will pretty
ok also over most of the details but for
a programmer induction right so you have
the input the alternative loops and
hacks that you want which is some action
x 3 and you define it say in this case
directly in the core language and you
want to induce rules of the following
form right just give you a few seconds
to look at it in this case maybe both of
them are fairly reasonable the first one
is higher precision and the second one
is more potentially a generalizable
right the second one is the first one
says it's this particular action you can
use this loop syntax whereas the second
one sells for any action you can use
these loops attacks and you can't really
yeah and the way you do it right find
some corresponding party and the
derivation tree a substitute them with
the variable right and build build up to
the lambda formula
so there isn't my good generic way to be
correct in all cases because there is
some contacts dependence and so so we
use we use the same model that we use to
score formulas to learn which rules to
abstract which is fairly similar to the
channel X approach from zero irn collins
except we we are very more aware higher
precision so basically i find out the
part that has the highest highest
scoring and abstract that out I'm
glossing over a lot of detail was due to
time so I want to show a little bit of
results so yeah and the questions we
have this process can people actually do
it so we we got a lot of but again a lot
of truckers to use the system and build
structures for us yeah and actually the
build really really impressive
structures yeah so the setup was we we
had a qualifier which which asked people
to build a fixed structure and once they
can build a fixed structure there is a
task we're over three days they can
build whatever they want we encourage a
little bit of conformity by running
competitions saying for each category
the best structure in that category gets
a prize but but people don't they don't
have to build things in these categories
and to the two also encouraged because
the point is really language learning we
want people to define things for us so
and the rule yeah those woods where yeah
so a rule gets a citation whenever is
used by another user and we have prize
for people with the highest each index
peanuts yeah okay so something looks the
last bit depends on also how well your
underlying algorithm is generalizing
right because if it takes an instruction
and it can generalize very heavily on
top of it then it will use this yeah
yeah yeah exactly yeah um yeah we'll
take a brief look at though what these
things look like so alright so the right
the left hand side are the structures
not people built and the steps that they
took to build it you'll see it's pretty
far away from the core language now and
yeah on the right hand side are is a
dealer board of a base now citations to
score is the citation I impact as the
h-index and it counts self self
citations goodness i don't know if it's
visible barely yeah so so in this case
right the rule was used in six hundred
ninety-nine times out of which 207 times
were used by the user himself and it
defined co-op 3s go up to and then go up
questions so how do they evaluate other
people's rules like that some name but
it's not clear what it does so they
don't really see the rules right that's
so they type something he and if they
accept the result and then a rule gets a
citation but I show the user to show the
system thinks user needs this rule
somehow guesses and proposals or someone
else types like go up three and then
than this room I get used
right so I see you guys here the system
guess is it may be the same thing system
curses oh that's all right what is so
from yeah so from each definition or one
or more rules cutscene used and that
rule is has property author the person
who gave the definition right and now no
it's just a rule but some annotation and
so if some other user types in another
utterance well and two parts of we need
to use some custom rules and so we parse
it with a custom rule which might may or
may not be correct but if the current
user likes it the user accepts the
action and on except the rule gets a
citation so so there's no visibility of
rule action by new users right so
they're just they're just doing whatever
their yeah yeah yeah they just they just
see ya yeah they just see this interface
when they when I do things there's also
no no autocomplete are here but they are
free to look at you neither born and see
like what they might be able to say oh
but they can't see the rules other
people use the yeah what they also have
access to the leaderboard tech but but
so right but we don't show the rules
only the definition that derives that
derive the rule because ruse has
categories and so on right it's very
ostrich to use a name drool from
somebody else do they get the logic for
free the citation for free or the logic
yes also if they use the rule from
somewhere else then that has whatever
meaning that the other person the
definer use right so after i defined
palm tree and everyone else can use
so if you define free and someone else
like types entry but they don't like
your trio so right so yeah you can maybe
see what was everything right so I I
palm tree and you don't like my tree and
maybe you want like some yellow top
right so so so maybe this is your like
add yellow tree yeah but then after
afterwards of other people use at yellow
tree than 0 perde I don't get any credit
for defining a palm tree it's only the
final rule so uh okay whoa yeah so
that's roughly what it looks like a lot
of pretty cool structures okay
so basic statistics for the experiment
or 42 workers participated who builds
230 structures in the process they
produce around 64 k addresses and of
which 36 k were accepts so no it's not
it checks out basic high leads to a data
point that's labeled by the derivation
and they gave just around two and half K
definitions from which we induced 2.8 k
rules and you can compare that with the
less 900 for the core language so is the
process of naturalization happening in
the process yes I think the result is
definitely yes in the beginning or it's
better the language has evolved from the
core two to what the user wants you so
this is okay so this is measured by the
percentage of assurances that are
stealing core or if it used induce rules
okay and then there's some amount that
we can parse at all right so no Amanda
can't parse at all drop slowly but the
but pretty quickly the amount of
utterances that using these rules over
takes that the amount i use only core
rules all right so in the end on the
right hand side is accepted get the
black lines for all users and the the
colored lines are for some of the
heaviest users right but there are some
difference in behavior right for example
the red users did stick more with the
core rules whereas the purple user and
the blue use are very quickly went to
their own space
but in the end for the last 10,000
accepted utterances seventy seven point
nine percent used induce rules and are a
candle and which means the alternates
cannot be parsing the core language okay
so I think that's pretty convincing in
terms of whether the language uses
evolving and then we can look at the as
a rough metric of expressive power we
look at the strand length of the program
over the number of tokens in the address
which is a run 10 for the core language
but I that and where the black eye is
for the overall user community we will
see this also grow very quickly as the
experiment goes on you also see a great
variation between different users right
so a very sore plausible reason for a
jump is when already used like more more
primitive concepts to define a higher
level concepts which leads to a big jump
in the length of the program well
there's this one user who basically just
use the I guess use core language
yourself the way the way this happens
right it can be just short forms turns
out people move a lot and the core
language for saying that is select left
of this which is fairly tedious so
people define things like left I'll have
two left you know the last night's I as
move left or select left a bunch of
other short forms for colors or
what-have-you right so you can define
things you can't define PR and as bra
implicitly through an utterance like a
bowl
more interestingly they can pick a
different syntax right so and is a set
of operation in a core language and here
the user wants to use it as sequencing
as the sequencing marker a more succinct
form for select a color where you know
how the oranges really just a color
value for the unicorn language and
together set you need to see has color
orange and because it's fairly common
the user is defiant selects orange yeah
different different loops and hats and
he always a recursive definition but one
that we cannot generalize for gravity
more more interestingly there's high
some amount of higher-level concepts
people define like had a black blog with
blood and high blah flower petals in
terms of flower petals things like a
cube got into position start and so on
right and you can you can see that I
used a lot in the leaderboard oh right
so if we look at citations 1000 of the
using these rules got some citations and
here's some subset of the top 50 most
cited rules and really highly sizes are
fairly simple things not everyone likes
like left 3 as a short form for like
repeat 3 select left yeah
something like zips long as a function
of you can see like loosely here
obviously it's not controlling for
complexity that frequency into putting
pressure evolutionary pressure on the
length of a string is see I think it's a
bit different right so so this is
because either a new user just happens
to thank the same way as the definer
then they will use the rule or are they
learn that from the leaderboard but
unlike tit and they are just keep using
it so yeah so they want they can
redefine it to another syntax but if
they want to use exactly this one and
they all give credit to the original be
fine yeah well basically I don't think
of it as like pressure towards simpler
things it's just you you need to do the
same for options and simpler actions a
lot more frequently to build stuff and
that's why yeah simple actions not
everyone needs that gets a higher
citation counts for in this case
question yeah so but maybe this is just
that if you are men the programming
language with some simple primitives
these kinds of primitives so then there
is nothing much more doing those
naturalization because everybody know
that's possible right but but some yeah
it's like what kind of diversity right
do you want to consider all the possible
ways that people want to say it by by
yourself or do you just want to or can
we just provide them one way to see it
and then they can figure out how yeah
how they want to see it in a way that
they like better right and so yeah but
but in addition to that right you also
have these like fairly complex concepts
in here right now this one probably
require either two boots or one sub
concept right
yeah and and we can't pause and so this
is like kind maybe us that a like a
library for your language and we can we
don't want to build that by your hand
for sure I think human human
anticipating all the syntax file by it
by handles yeah once you run this
experiment you learn this simple
customization and beyond that it may be
very hard to yeah as a lot of Ewing
remains remains to be seen right yeah so
in the end is there only the global
vocabulary and build the tree so it's
not yeah yeah yeah so it's not so good
if ever if people conflict with each
other and under France rule whether
friends feature will get down with it a
lot but it's still very possible yeah
well by the hoof is right there might be
many different versions of flowers and
will support all of them and when when
people typing add flour there will be a
list of different flowers they can yeah
flower defined with multiple yeah yeah
yeah yeah so like yeah pro yeah the
parser is definitely supports and acuity
wait okay so the goal was really to
bridge the power between now the current
natural language interfaces with the
power of programming language in order
to handle complex actions with do it you
know shared community setting and
hopefully this can be to language
interface that's good for beginners and
experts alike
interesting about how jargon or like a
kind of pidgin language develops yeah I
think it definitely varies a lot by
users right so yeah so this user really
likes the goals and hats right and other
users barely use it for in terms of just
that the domain we don't quite have like
yeah I don't think we observe big
differences between the objects they are
building be yeah perhaps the parts are
not quite that generalizable yeah but
you definitely see very and big
variation between user preferences
and so to come we cover two different
extremes so in the learning language
game setting with start from scratch and
anything goes the system just tries it's
best to figure things out in the
naturalizing programming language
approach we start with the full
programming language one where we had a
private language and where we had a
community with some user modeling using
selection as supervision versus the more
powerful definition but more more
powerful but also more cumbersome
definition and supervision but that
allows us to build up to more complex
actions and concepts so in one case
where we use the learning from the
notation to do most of the heavy lifting
and in doing so we are fairly language
agnostic yeah other case we use grammar
induction to do the heavy lifting and
parsing a very precise way so unless
there are precise rules applying with
don't parse so we tried to do to the use
apply the same math approach to a
calendar setting and we're the same
language there's a blog post I'll point
you to but say much more yeah so the
goal of our research is really to enable
up at her language interface with the
computers as speech is getting better we
explore to setting to I think in some
sense out posing settings and one is
perhaps the vegan style view where
language derives its meaning from use
and the other is not Montague of you
it's not a direct quote but perhaps
language derives its meeting from its
definition yeah and that's so my talk
thank
[Applause]
it's just curious a little bit the
different experiments do you have any
idea about backgrounds of your turker
this is how experienced they were as
programmers themselves and thinking like
it'd be great to try this out with
school kids of different ages and see
yeah yeah valid experts yeah so so I
think by and large the Turkish or not
experts before the qualifier we do the
survey where where they were asked to it
for their programming experience and
roughly I think two-thirds that no and
roughly winters that some make spurious
but I don't have the exact number with
me right now oh yeah I guess use those
as the people who can program pretty
well it can find a better job nowadays
and I'm doing Turk or days or so you can
feel fairly confident yeah I'm wondering
how important is the curriculum this
sequence of tasks say in the first part
for example where initially nobody has
really any information and so you have a
monkey and typewriters kind of problem
you know you have people just having to
type random things and hope that their
intent is close enough in the list at
else and so you know I kind of
constrained to main menu have a sequence
of those so is there like a key design
decision or done would it just work to
make up any old combination of things I
think for that part of the important
decision just because partially also
communicates the other go attack what
kind of actions you can do and the first
Oh like yeah yeah yeah like well like
look no I I mean to the contrast between
the start and go state right partially
it communicates what actions are
available yeah whereas a I don't think
that the Linguistics the other names
here are the matters at all but yeah so
right and so that this thing suggests
that maybe like left is the important
yeah so the thing that makes it
significantly easier wherever whereas if
you just start people you know why odd
than they all have a much it's some kind
of its showing all the gradients right
yeah atomic action can perform this
greedy right yeah it's roughly through
teaching it some really short logical
forms and then some simple simple
compositions hard slightly more complex
composition so this is like all but cyan
right
how many are having the like in the
domain such as having the algorithm or
the computer generate the examples that
wants sort of the human translation so
so you have two tasks where for the
first one you get some human well I have
to compute generate all the other
examples regenerate other problem I see
is also like all possible logical forms
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah you can yeah we
can definitely do the do it more
systematically
did you very different oh I you only did
one experiment so you're in quite
different starting job but this is great
but the possible sequences is so big
space to explore we would just pick one
and not not yet I don't think we would
spend that much
three what
[Applause]